um john
i'm going to put you on the floor you're
up so what is your policy i know you've
never
been married but what's your policy on
ltrs and managing money
every girl i've been with is absolutely
atrocious with money
and it's just if you look at the data
women are
terrible with money women spend the most
money
women are targeted by governments and
big corporations
because they're easy to manipulate
emotionally to extract
finances and votes from them i see
i was in the bed the other day with this
chick and i saw her checking her bank
account she thought i was sleeping
she's 29 years old she had 300 bucks in
her bank account i was just like
you're [ __ ] you are so irrefutably
[ __ ]
she works in the fashion industry too to
top it off um
when i get into an ltr of the chicks um
you know miss mld she is uh
approaching six figures in her crypto um
investment account and she's been with
me this in the market since
uh when did she get in or i think q2
2017 so um when i
if a girl is going to you know be
privileged to be around me
she has to listen to what i tell her to
do with finances
i will never ever in my life
put a woman on a joint bank account
joint credit account
joint lease she she doesn't even have a
key to my house and she's never gonna
have one
okay i don't even put like the most risk
i've exposed myself to
is i'm on her cell phone
uh plan but she's liable for all of the
uh the payments and everything i pay her
at the end of the month because
in japan it's just so hard for a
foreigner to get a credit card and you
need a credit card
to sign up with a softbank but um
other than that like like i advise every
guy to go through a chick's phone
and just see how much of their life is
just chaotic and just
absolute a complete mess head to toe
these chicks
now more than ever are completely lost
and the last thing on their mind let
alone the line
on the minds of men is financial
responsibility
and investments they are spending money
as soon as it gets to their bank account
they are they are putting venti
starbucks coffees
on a credit card with 22 apr all right
that's how bad they are with money so if
you're a
fool dumb enough to think
oh well i love her and it's the right
thing to do
so i'm gonna put her on my credit card
it's time for me to man up
it's time for me to be that better beta
you're full and you deserve the
financial damnation that's coming your
way
you